I flip up in the air I was actually like
face up and had to like go like this and
react as if he hit me to the ground
if you watch this movie there's always
some of my gang wrecked boom where'd the
car come from oh my God this is awesome
no that guy no no dude no don't the car
is not safe all right so here's what
happened
thanks to copilot for sponsoring this
episode Stick Around to find out how you
can get started with your own Expert
Fitness and health coach today what's up
everybody welcome back to another
episode of stuntman react this is gonna
be a good episode we got the oest of the
G's here Eric Linden
the very first stunt man to ever be in a
stuntman react episode and of course gee
is here as well what's up y'all let's
just get right into it we got good Clips
I can't wait to show these guys I have a
list of like four Cliffs that Eric has
not heard of it's gonna be a good time
up
hey so you worked on Black Adam yeah yes
I worked on Black Adam which was which
was really cool to get to see how they
did this this particular scene in the
Tomb they were using that bolt cam
they have a track across the entire
stage inside this tomb and they did a
lot with practical sets where of course
there's some blue screen behind it but
that whole tomb was there and this bolt
cam runs across a track across the floor
it also has this like articulating uh
like robot arm the idea at least that
didn't end up making it into this they
they cut it up was that Black Adam Zips
around and catches everybody yeah kicks
the crap out of everybody uh so we would
do it all in one shot but we would only
do one gag at a time so the bolt cam
would go this gag would go boom we need
to fly away and they'd go like this and
move through the rest of nobody there
and then we did the number two number
three and number four and so on and so
you weren't trying to run them all at
once and a lot there was a lot of wire
gags in there oddly enough I ended up
doing two of them which I still wasn't
sure how that was going to make any
sense in the edit and it was probably my
fault they had to edit it honestly
the next guy with the beard really hard
poor mercenaries don't even know what
they're getting themselves into I'm
right there boom and I go flying and
then that's me
if I did this wire you know the old
Gooch wrap where they I flip up in the
air so as I come out of the the rap I
was actually like face up and had to
like go like this and react as if he hit
me to the ground well then they just you
know they scan you and this is a perfect
example where the beginning of the gag
is me right up until he punches me but I
hadn't finished the gag so then that's
my CGI double me me me me double because
that never happened I was supposed to
get punched in the chest and then they
made it so punch me in the back yeah he
was supposed to take out the majority of
us all in this sequence right here all
in one shot they cut it up into a make
it seem like he was killing more people
I mean it came out very similar to the
animatics but these animatics they did
were amazing it was really really good
experience boom next lightning round
right
pretty rad brawl oh
that was a great switch round back kick
this is making contact
[Music]
like just put everybody in mask if we
kill someone just slap the mask on the
next guy
[Music]
who even knows what's Breakaway anymore
oh my gosh
pure Mayhem I love it dude how fun would
the scene just be to be in yeah and
they're like okay once we hit this one
Mark just everybody go ape [__] I think
it was done by the Thai stunt team that
worked with Tony jaw at the time and so
that's why it's like such a hard-hitting
like if you watch this movie there's
always somebody getting wrecked like
really bad yeah
boom where'd the car come from it just
gets wild oh my God everybody this is
awesome
that car is Oprah Winfrey you get a hit
you get a hit
it just looks so dangerous
oh
if you're going in a circle like that
and you're pulling off one of these gags
like the idea wherever you hit is that
you want to go to the outside of the car
and so anybody's going to the inside not
not great one thing I would say if I was
had to do this is that I would drive the
car slow and have everybody on timing
run and hit it and figure out which way
they were going to go right some of
that's for camera but also some of it's
for safety like that one guy probably
always jumps up over the car there's a
real nice split of people I think if
this was completely willy-nilly you
would have a lot more people going to
one side instead of it like looking so
pretty right
um they definitely probably had the car
still and then everybody just ran their
course at it yeah yeah you do really
plan you do it five miles an hour and
work your way up and work your way up so
everybody's like yeah and I think when
you're going full speed there's some
variability to this but now everybody
kind of knows that yeah you watch
closely you said everybody's actually
like dismounting the car on their own
terms right and and they know how long
the shot's gonna go what a great clip
good one
this is a recommended comment clip and
there's some great great recommendation
guys in those recommendations so this
clip Attack of the Killer Tomatoes also
in the comments there's so many gems in
the last stunt react episode so thank
you please these these obscure amazing
stunts they're the best ones all right
you know I've already seen like you know
marvel stunts right what about that one
crazy stunt in that movie from 1975
[Music]
here comes the helicopter for landing
with our heroes whoops no no
no no no no no
oh no
oh they just cut to the destruction
they're like yeah
they're fine
they're perfectly fine yeah that thing
is just scorched Earth all around it and
they get up without a scratch on them
this is part of that's part of the movie
it does look like that was like
no that is actually an accident
the the guys didn't die that were flying
the helicopter they crashed it and
they're like we need to put that in the
movie so they got the insert shot to the
actors reacting and then the actors that
were in the helicopter are off the side
going I could just see that a tornado I
didn't see anything
crazy and I love how like none of the
actors in The foreground know that this
is happening until the rotors hit the
ground and the guy just stops acting
boom and the guy like what
laughs
does it make you wonder like what was
supposed to happen you're just supposed
to just land like he came in came in a
little too hot yeah can't get that stuff
like you couldn't choreograph or
coordinate something like this IRL I
don't think without like no you'd never
be allowed to like yeah you're gonna
crash this helicopter into this field
yeah until you said it was real I was
just going to be like oh that's like a
forced perspective model right you know
that they were like some really nice
model shot attacking the Killer Tomatoes
the rest of this clip is them shooting
tomatoes with Guns by the way yeah I
think if it oh really yeah they're gonna
just they're literally a tomato field
they're shooting tomatoes
I mean nobody in this whole thing ever
said like why was the uh helicopter in
such a hurry because he was trying to
catch up
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh okay Tora Tora Tora it's a movie
about Pearl Harbor came out a while back
uh Tora Tora Tora was the code word for
the Japanese for launching the attack
that was like the go word okay
um check out this sequence coming up
no
oh no oh dude go go go keep going go go
you keep moving don't the car is not
safe all right so here's what happened
it was initially like a remote
controlled plane
um set up with explosives right and it's
supposed to be on the runway and blow up
on the runway it goes off course and
flies into these planes with all these
extras this is not planned and they're
always like ah running for their lives
and then the pyrotechnics go off in the
area why didn't they keep running they
keep rolling after this like if you
watch like this happens boom boom boom
explosives go off everybody's just like
oh my God I almost died and keeps it all
like he's acting yeah he rolling yeah he
frames up cameraman isn't like Jaw to
the floor he just like I'm getting this
rolling gentlemen keep run back to the
explosions please and they're all like
that'd be such an experience to film
this you know yeah
can you imagine just like logistically
needing to have like a place for what
was that 10 12 planes to take off from
he's like how do you get your marks well
they do the shot they gotta do the shot
and I'm assuming go back and land again
you'd have to land then they have to
reset all right you guys in position all
these people running through it's not
like the planes do a loop and then come
back and just do it again yeah that's
the hardest thing about aerial Vehicles
it's like okay they'll be right there
this is our shot like is it gonna be
right there will they be right there
will the timing work out this actually
reminds me of a story about a shady car
from Expendables 3. Jose a huge black
guy so yeah there's like janky little
truck to watch closely you can see two
camera guys just get blasted watch how
long they commit to getting this shot
get in the shot getting the shot getting
the shot still getting the shot still
getting the shot hasn't even reacted
he goes maybe that right that little
pause right there might have saved him
before it completely goes on yeah can
you imagine the weight of a truck
smashing you into the water that'd be
pretty bad I think that it bottomed just
enough time to like fall clear of it
Jason Statham was a professional diver
he's like I'll just get out once we hit
the water that's what he thinks to
himself but all the water rushing in
pins into the seats he's like instead
I'll just hold my breath until we go
underwater and just swim out up to the
surface like literally just rides into
action action heroes back at the top
hell yeah yeah pretty impressive the
fact they just keep shooting of course
Sylvester Stallone's just filmed him
with his iPhone
speaking Stallone speaking Stallone we
actually have the little stunt clip from
Rambo
[Applause]
this is old 80s action stuff that I love
this oh so that's not that's not so long
though yeah yeah that's just good old
high fall yep I believe this is Stallone
yeah here
there it is that's still on yep so I
broke his rib what right there
oh oh man oh and look at it he totally
didn't have to do that shot
[Laughter]
nowadays it's a good chance you wouldn't
even do that uh you you would just put
him on a wire all the way all the way
down all the way the ability to paint on
wires is totally like changed stunts
completely probably have some sort of
location but I think for the detail of
him going through the trees there'd
probably just be you know fake branches
on set so you could guarantee that these
things aren't going to snap fake fake
tree branches they're like kind of
padded that look like tree that are
painted to look like trees right right I
mean they're just doing this out in the
woods like you know they probably kind
of like get up there and hang on the
branch and they're like yeah this is
good seems good that's a wild stunt Eric
Linden is like dashing a double rainbow
the first double rainbow if you're not
subscribed you might miss it when he
shows up so make sure you're subscribed
[Music]
Merry Christmas uh so this I this is
also like my big love for like movies
from the 80s and the 90s like I just
grew up watching this stuff and was
probably way too young to be watching
Lethal Weapon but uh this is another one
of these things that just kind of stuck
in my mind as uh one of those things
that's made me want to do stunts in
movies yeah
take our time both die of cancer Riggs
pops out here to try to talk the guy
down and starts to connect with him and
then proceeds to
slap a handcuff on him so now he can't
kill himself but Riggs is actually a
little bit crazy as well and is like oh
yeah pal you want to jump you want to
jump okay let's do this
[Music]
see the handcuffs came apart I didn't
see that right and then grabbed a hold
of his hand last second wow to make the
gag work saved it I know that is far
that's so scary and he starts oh no oh
no oh no boom so you just don't want him
landing on top of you when you hit that
airbag yeah yeah and you can see how one
guy kind of got as he reached for that
guy it might have kind of pulled his
momentum a little little cattywampus or
something or one guy started to turn
before the other guy and it kind of
pulls him around man I might even want
to go into boxes because if I hit the
airbag first I get it all and you get
zero so uh or a lot less I can tell you
that so it's like pretty important to
hit it essentially the same time so
you're getting both getting that D cell
do they use airbags anymore these days
uh yeah definitely
um I don't think I think most of the
time you're gonna opt for wires
um just safety and repeatability and um
footprint and all that stuff and be able
to get a camera angle it didn't have a
giant airbag in it uh you know wires is
the way to go what's up guys Christian
here and as you know I've been very open
about my health and fitness journey over
the last few months on this channel
which is why I'm very excited to tell
you about today's sponsor co-pilot
copilot is a awesome personal training
personalized coaching fitness app and
it's super easy basically you take a
short survey based on your goals and
they match me with my coach Devin I had
an onboarding call after about 30
minutes we talked about my fitness goals
how much time I want to spend in the gym
how many days a week I want to spend in
the gym and what equipment I had
available and in the next day or two he
had built out a whole calendar schedule
full of my personalized workouts based
on my goals there's personalized guides
on how the list should be done he tells
you exactly how many reps and how much
weight you should be using with the rest
times in between it's all almost as if
you're working out with a personal
trainer in person right next to you and
if you're an Apple watch user it gets
even better I was just lifting weights
one day in the gym and my coach told me
to slow down literally based off my apps
in my ear he goes slow down your reps
and I was I slowed down my ribs and all
of a sudden he goes That's better it's
super integrated it's literally as if he
was standing there right next to me
Devin's there in real time after every
workout I put in some feedback I said
hey that was a little lighter on weight
or hey that was a little too heavy he is
there to be my accountability partner
and my support partner to make sure I am
continuously on it and keeping me in a
good Rhythm and consistency in my
workout schedule and a fun fact over 75
percent of co-pilot users that work out
for 100 days continue to work out past
that hundred days it literally builds
routines and consistency to keep you on
your health Journey long term have you
ever considered wanting a personal
trainer but thought it was too expensive
or you never had the time and it was
never flexible enough for you I think
copilot is a perfect program for you and
if you would like to get started go to
go.myco-pilot.com quarter crew or just
hit that link at the top of the
description and get your free trial with
your own expert health and fitness coach
today that's
go.myco-pilot.com quarter crew so you
can get a free trial to get started with
your own health and fitness expert today
that's about it I love hearing you guys
feedback so hit me up with any questions
I'll be on my co-pilot program but in
the meantime let's get back to Eric
Linden on the couch for some stents yeah
I love I love this stuff because uh you
know when I was growing up you just
sometimes you go back and you and you'll
look at something that seems way bigger
than you look at you're like oh geez but
it's just my imagination as a kid but
there's some really gnarly stuff that
they used to do yeah but they would
never do now they would just cgid or or
it would be all fake and to some extent
or on wires and they were real cowboys
awesome I'm not very first to End Eric
you need to come back to LA more
frequently yeah
well thank you guys for having me back
again this is always so much fun and
finally get together yeah
we haven't had you sign the couch yet I
don't think no no yeah you're like
you're one of the like Originators like
we've been saving a spot for you it'll
be huge how can people follow you these
days uh just uh the only thing I'm
really active on is Instagram at Eric
Linden but yeah I'm always happy to
answer questions uh and I literally do
it all the time people will ask me
something specific or ask me to look at
their short and I literally answer every
single person that's really nice of you
it's a that's a big problems you're
making here to a lot of people that's a
lot but seriously that's that's very
very generous of you to do that as
always it's a pleasure thank you so much
for joining us this is our last day
we're filming this on our last day in
December before we do our little winter
break here and come back in January and
yeah what a nice way to end the year
yeah yeah thank you guys
sweet well see you guys in the next one
I hope you liked it peace
yeah
hi we're back we just hit 6 million
subscribers The Breakfast of Champions
right here it is uh 11 A.M and we're
about to start a day what could go wrong
if we eat a bunch of sugar in the
morning to be like a million things
going on this year we're trying to
invent a whole new like animation style
for an anime video we're gonna be
regenerating a bunch of models here and
like doing these translations using
stable diffusion which is very much like
an unproven process we've got local zero
to finally get made an Unreal Engine
we're making dubstep guns too we're
making wizard cops again like there's a
lot of stuff going on and to do it we
need some infrastructure I'm gonna start
with a truss so you can put up lights
and people above the green screen
we got a ton of trust
we have six runs of 10 foot trust a lot
of boxes and three additional two foot
trusses I'm gonna combine all that have
22 feet runs it goes up in the studio